I just want to thank you because you're
very very special people you were here
long before any of us were here
although we have a representative in
Congress who they say was here a long
time ago
they call her Pocahontas
but you know what
I like you because you are special you
are special people you are really
incredible people
ah that one is an oldie but a goodie
hello I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's October 6 2022 we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV
uh subscribe tap that notification Bell
if you have not and because I cannot
tell a lie people I do have to admit
right up top although I said it's
October 6th in reality you're watching
this live streamed on October 6 at 11
A.M Eastern as usual uh but in reality
it is Tuesday October 4th and we
pre-taped this because I am at the
hospital right now because uh our
surrogate is giving birth and we were
inducing she was close to the 40 weeks
it's all good so I could be a double
father as you're watching this right now
we'll have more info on that soon uh but
obviously very exciting time I think one
or two of the questions from the
reubenreport.locals.com uh Community uh
are referring to that so we'll get to
that in just a sec I wanted to do one
story up top this this week because this
is sort of big or maybe it's not
anything but it kind of fits everything
that's going on in the world at the
moment the orange man Donald Trump who
may or may not be running for president
he is for sure suing uh the clown
Network known as CNN and uh you know
it's sort of sort of interesting he
wants about 400 million dollars from
them which is half of Don lemon's salary
so we're going to get to that and a
bunch of questions but real quick let's
talk about bullion Max you guys know
that as inflation surpasses highs not
seen in 40 years the value of the dollar
is decreasing with every passing day
you're paying more at the pump the
grocery store for cars for housing face
it your paper money is worth less
friends the time couldn't be any better
for my new sponsor bullion Max Boolean
Max is a direct to Consumer precious
metals retailer who can help you
diversify into gold and silver it's a
hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
Crisis and here's why I love bullying
max they're owned by veterans in the
precious metal space offer some of the
lowest prices on the internet
and they make it so easy to buy directly
from their website I wanted to help you
get started so I worked out a special
offer just for you get bullion Max's
silver starter kit that employee pricing
just go to booleanmax.com Dave the kit
includes five of the most desirable
silver products to invest in including a
silver American eagle and a silver
Australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to booleanmax.com Dave and
now back to me so yes former president
and possibly future president Donald
Trump is suing CNN we've got some info
from the daily wire former president
Donald Trump announced his intent to sue
CNN and other cable networks on
Wednesday that have defamed him and
defrauded the public about the 2020
election media hosts on networks such as
CNN and others have baselessly suggested
that Trump is a Russian agent or
suggested that Trump won the 20 16
election because of Russian interference
I have notified CNN of my intent to file
a lawsuit over their repeated defamatory
statements against me Trump said in a
statement I will also be commencing
actions against other media Outlets who
have defamed me and defrauded the public
regarding the overwhelming evidence of
fraud throughout the 2020 election I
will never stop fighting for the truth
and for the future of our country the
notice goes on to address the 2020
election claiming that the Network's use
of referring to Trump's claims about the
election as the big lie are also
defamatory as it suggests that the
former president is willfully misleading
the public rather than stating what he
believes to be true okay so there's a
whole bunch here first off Donald Trump
gets in a lot of lawsuits with a lot of
people sometimes he's the one putting
the lawsuit down sometimes he's the one
on the on the defense when it comes to
these lawsuits my gut feeling is that
that he is not going to win this lawsuit
I mean you sort of have to be careful
when you get into these things about
defamation and libel and slander and all
that like look think about all of the
times even in the couple years last
couple years of me doing this show when
I've talked about things that the New
York Times has said about me literally
putting my picture on the front page
calling me one of the leaders of the
alt-right all of the lies about
everybody Brett Kavanaugh is a serial
rapist the Covington kids are all racist
like it's part and parcel sort of of
what comes with free speech at the
moment and we do have these very very
specific and and stringent laws around
libel and slander otherwise everybody
would be suing everybody all the time
and basically everyone would be afraid
to exercise their free speech so it
wouldn't be a direct infringement on
your Free Speech but if you were
constantly silencing yourself we'd have
a problem that being said plenty of
people are silencing themselves all the
time but it's usually not because
they're afraid that they're going to get
sued for liable or slander it's usually
because they think they're going to get
canceled or fired or kicked off social
media et cetera et cetera anyway the guy
wants 475 million from CNN my guess is
yeah it'll this will probably be thrown
out in court maybe it's just a little
more of him trying to get into the news
perhaps deflect a little bit about the
Mar-A-Lago raid or something like that
but at the end of the day I think what
Trump really has to figure out is if he
is going to run and everyone is saying
he's going to run although he is known
to surprise people so it's like if
everyone's saying he's going to run
maybe the big surprise is that he
doesn't and that he backs DeSantis and
who knows right but if he's going to run
he has a huge problem on his hand
because if he as he's saying earnestly
believes that the election was stolen
let's say that that's his position the
election was stolen one way or another
uh then why wouldn't they steal it from
you again unless you've done something
to stop the steel right so if you if you
haven't done anything to to stop the
steel then your candidacy doesn't really
make sense oh they stole it from me last
time now I'm just going to run again
that's a problem that's a problem uh
we've got some info on the actual
lawsuit from Reuters Trump a republican
claims in the 29-page lawsuit that CNN
had a long track record of criticizing
him but had ramped up its attacks in
recent months because the network feared
that he would run again for president in
2024 as a part of its concerted effort
to tilt the political balance to the
left CNN has tried to taint the
plaintiff with a series of ever more
scandalous false and defamatory labels
of racist Russian Lackey
insurrectionists and ultimately Hitler
the lawsuit claims look this is where I
would say although I don't think
anything will come of the lawsuit it's
like should they be a little bit scared
should somebody put the fear of God in
these people and make them understand
that they cannot lie about absolutely
everybody and that may be calling
everybody you disagree with a Nazi and a
homophobia and a bigot and a transphobe
is not really the best thing to do so
maybe this like Turned the screws a
little bit and CNN behaves a little bit
better but if I was a betting man I
would not bet on that all right let's
get to the Reuben report dot locals.com
Community Q a Elizabeth says what do you
think the Dave of 15 years ago would
think of where you are now Dave of 15
years ago so 15 years ago
2007 I am uh 41 years no 40 31 years old
geez I just aged myself uh I'm in New
York City I'm I'm doing stand up I was
basically broke I was handing out
tickets in Times Square two hours a
night six nights a week just to get a
couple people to show up at the comedy
clubs and maybe I could make a couple
bucks and I was doing all sorts of odd
jobs on the side and I was bartending
and waiting tables and working in
promotions companies and just just
anything to make a dime so I could
survive
um I guess he'd be pretty pretty
impressed right like I got to the other
side of the thing I eventually in 2013 I
moved to LA
the show started taking off I've gone
independent a couple times I built and
sold a tech company that just went
public like things are things are pretty
good so I think I think he would be
pretty impressed I think I'd probably be
maybe shocked that I'm married and have
kids I guess that that would be a
shocker but uh yeah it kind of worked
out Knock on Wood uh Freedom fan says I
know it'll be a few years but when the
boys are old enough will Disney World be
on your family road trip agenda it's
funny you asked this one because this
came up a couple days ago so look I
canceled Disney Plus
I hate what they've done to Star Wars
I'm also not into chopping kids genitals
off so I don't like their General broad
outlook on the world over there at
Disney uh you know they've gone woke
with absolutely everything it's all
propaganda the movies aren't even that
good anymore
the list goes on and on the Marvel
movies are just all repetitive now and
all that stuff
um so I have said to David a couple
times I'm like I don't think we're gonna
go like I'm not taking them to Disney
World or any of this stuff I did say we
could get the old like we'll have to
figure out how to download them I think
like my parents probably have some of
the old DVDs of old school Disney movies
right like I don't want to deprive the
kids of the original Lion King let's say
something like that or the original
Little Mermaid or whatever
but I don't think I can be part of this
thing I don't like funding my own demise
I don't like funding things that are
that are antithetical to the ideas that
I talk about here David's like a little
bit different on that his feeling is
well you know it's sort of it is just
sort of the thing and are we gonna not
show our kids the new Disney movies and
all that stuff so we're gonna have to
Hash that one out he's not like full on
pushing it unfortunately we have a
couple years and hopefully Disney will
continue to crumble over a couple years
and then there'll be a whole maybe
there'll just be a wider swap of actual
decent programming to show the kids but
I can't imagine taking them there like
I've been on the teacups they're not
that great frankly you've been on the
teacups it's a little nauseating you're
spinning you know you're spinning like
this and then you're also spinning
within the spin it's it's too much uh
Casey says they've got a ditch Kamala
before they ditch Joe how are they gonna
do it this is interesting because Joe
obviously is breaking down he's not
making it the four years we all know it
there's a scandal that will erupt around
it because somebody knows what's really
going on with him what they're drugging
him with how much worse than we're
publicly seeing it it actually is Dr
Jill Biden obviously has not diagnosed
him properly like everyone's in on the
thing but yes I may not you know be a
supporter of Joe Biden or his policies
but as I always say he's the pilot of
the plane and it's like if he steps down
or they kick him out then Kamala Harris
who I think is a genuine idiot like like
dumb really not bright I also think
she's a racist she believes that
government age should be based on your
skin color that is the definition of
racism if a republican said that they
would be called a racist right she's
also a communist I mean she said you've
seen the video many times she has fully
said and she said it repeatedly by the
way she was even saying this before the
election she wants us all to end up in
the same spot that is literally the
definition of communism it does not
matter what your skills are what your
work ethic is what you do you want to
end up in the same spot she doesn't mean
it for herself or her friends but she
means it for all of you so it would not
be better if Kamala Harris was president
I don't know what they're going to do
but they have to be talking about it
they have to be talking about it and by
they I don't know what I'm you know I
don't know is that uh Obama machine
Clinton machine whatever that is but
they've got to figure out a way because
otherwise Biden steps down you get come
out like I don't know I still think it
has something to do with Gavin Newsom I
think he is somehow that slimy lizard
freak I think is just somehow in the mix
over there I should spit every time I
say Gavin Newsom uh Miss mama panda says
you recently posted a picture of the
evening sky in Miami would you consider
our Florida sunsets the best in the U.S
let me be clear I love the free state of
Florida have you ever heard me say that
this is the most wonderful place I they
can bury me in the Everglades I'm never
leaving I will give everything I have to
defend this place and everything it has
afforded me in terms of life and freedom
and all that good stuff that being said
I don't know that we have the best
sunsets we're very flat it's very flat
here you're not going to get your kind
of mountainous Sunset that's generally
to me if you get a sunset kind of going
over some mountains Sun's dipping down
that might be better I used to love love
love and I hope I will get back there
sometime soon the the sun sets on
Sanibel used to be out on the beach six
o'clock rolls down and that sun just
dipping below the Horizon over there but
yeah we're pretty flat here so I I don't
want to say California Santa Fe New
Mexico I've never even been there but I
feel like they got a pretty decent
Sunset Wayne says do you think the
Supreme Court will reform section 230 no
I don't think anything's happening with
this stuff I I just don't I don't know
the Machinery is just sort of so broken
that there was a time remember a couple
years ago when everyone was really
waking up to Big Tech censorship and
Rand Paul
Ted Cruz Josh Hawley a couple other guys
they were dragging out Zuckerberg and
Jack Dorsey from Twitter and they were
grilling them on all of this stuff and
you know there was this basic idea that
section 230 which in essence makes the
distinction between a platform and and a
uh and a content provider meaning that
if you're gonna have an open-ended
platform which is what we thought all
these things were Twitter Facebook Etc
that you can't censor content it's like
people put the content up there if it
breaks the law then they have a bigger
problem but that it was an open platform
versus a content provider which in
essence would be like the daily wire the
daily wire which produces certain
content is liable for the content that
they produce on their Network that's the
distinction that 230 is constantly
talking about I think maybe the best
thing we could get out of this is that
the the big tech companies would all be
considered common carriers so they'd be
treated more like a t right like so Alex
Jones who's been kicked off of all the
tech platforms I'm pretty sure he still
has a telephone right the government uh
is not able to not allow at T to give
him a telephone I think I'm pretty sure
that's how it works so you could maybe
do something like that but honestly my
feeling at this point is
basically we need all new everything we
need new Gmail we need new Google we
need new search engines we need new
YouTubes we need new patreons and by the
way I'm building some of those things
that's why I started locals.com that's
why we merged with Rumble and we are
building the parallel pipes of the
Internet it's it's as simple as that
talway says I don't know if this
question has been asked before but who
were some of your personal Heroes
growing up and what sort of people will
you be showcasing to your kids as people
to look up to that's a good one you know
one for sure that uh this wasn't in my
personal life but just someone that I
used to watch from a distance and love
even though I was very young I remember
watching Johnny Carson
when I was probably like 10 11 years old
and I just thought he was so funny and
decent and he was just like this nice
man on television and he wasn't
screaming and you know he had he had
this nice smile and I always remember
actually when he was doing the monologue
he would have one hand in his pocket
during the monologue and I've realized
in years since when when I'm on stage
book tour doing stand-up whatever I
usually have one hand in my pocket I
think it has something to do with that
he just seemed like this he was just
kind of relaxed and enjoying the thing
for what it was
um and that kind of uh
not bludgeoning of the audience right
like everyone on late night now they
just bludgeon these people endlessly
with their politics and their views and
uh and he he wasn't like that and I
think that's partly why things were
better what sort of people will you be
showcasing to your kids as people to
look up to you look I'm very fortunate
uh in that I know some really
spectacular people that you know could
give some serious insight to these kids
I mean I mentioned to you guys just a
few days before Justin was born we we
had Jordan Peterson and Dennis Prager
over for dinner and I got to just kind
of Grill them on all the questions of
fatherhood it's like Justin's middle
name is Jordan in honor of Jordan
Peterson I don't know have I even said
that publicly before I'm not sure I've
even said that publicly but it is it's
like Jordan Peterson can babysit him and
I bet he can impart some pretty good
stuff on him uh Dennis can do a little
babysitting that seems like a movie
doesn't that seem like that seems like a
Disney movie Dennis breaker like
babysitting the kids
um so yeah we're surrounded by a lot of
people that they'll get some some good
messaging from uh Candace says did you
see the absolute meltdown from Kanye
West and Candace Owens wearing the White
live matters shirts maybe the media will
be forced to say all lives matter so
yeah this is in the last couple days uh
there's the picture right there there's
Candace and Kanye White lives matter
look Candace you guys know my feelings
about Candace she's one of my best
friends on planet Earth I I absolutely
adore her the fact that when she was
sort of
you know like a YouTube Nobody with 50
000 subscribers and I didn't even know
her name she was known as red pill black
and I had her on YouTube week on my show
years ago I just knew she was gonna
light the world on fire I absolutely
knew it and she has just done it one
thing after another she is so grown into
who she's supposed to be she's a
wonderful wife and parent and all of
that but she man she loves she loves
poking these people and these people
deserve to be poked and excused uh and
poked and and mocked so uh I'm not
surprised that the media is having a
meltdown over this and they're trying to
make it seem like Anderson and Kanye or
white supremacists but yeah these they
do need to be mocked right what do I say
you guys like we gotta mock them and
then we also have to build better things
at the same time and it's like wait a
minute wait a minute if black lives
matter means something well okay black
people's lives matter into white
people's lives matter
call me old school I think everyone
lives
old school
crazy mom says Dave how much do you and
David love being parents it's been
pretty great so far again I'm taping
this there could be a second child right
at this very moment might have gotten
much harder right at that moment I could
be holding two bottles two babies it
could be a lot but it's been it's been
really good actually it's you know we've
got great family and friends around us
so we've had some help David's really
like just stepped into this role these
kids are are being taken care of really
well you know waking up in the morning
and I've told you guys before I do the
the 8 A.M feeding so like I start my day
you know holding Justin and we sit up
there and Clyde gets on the couch with
us and and it's a lot better than being
on Twitter so uh you know I suspect as
the years go by and we can do more he
doesn't talk yet for example I assume as
there's a little talking we can you know
do some more stuff throw a ball around
that kind of thing that it'll it'll keep
expanding and yeah it's been uh it's
been a blessing uh Nathan says hey Dave
I have to tell you that you are my
favorite journalist journalist and air
quotes who isn't an actual journalist to
get my daily dose of headlines from with
modern day journalism practically dead
what future do you think journalism
still has does it have some promise that
organizations like Fox News Newsmax The
Blaze Etc this is tough because
journalism
old school I'm going to tell the truth
no matter what I'm going to put my life
at risk and my career at risk journalism
it doesn't really seem to exist anymore
that's not to say that it's completely
gone it does exist to some level Andy no
who has been tracking antifa for the
last couple years at Great risk to him
personally professionally physically all
that stuff like he's a journalist
there's not many of these people anymore
and you know even when uh when we're
sourcing stories for the show and
Phoenix and I are going back and forth
on stuff it's like we have to make sure
that the sources are going to make sense
we do choose a lot of stuff from the
daily wire I think they do a pretty good
job we choose a lot of stuff from The
Blaze I think they do a pretty good job
but are they somewhat on my team well of
course they are so it's getting harder
and harder to trust anything and I think
what will continue to happen is
basically why I'm your most trusted
journalist even though I'm not a
journalist which is that you you believe
and I believe it as well obviously I'm
basically trying to tell you something
true I'm going to make mistakes there is
no doubt about it I'm not going to make
all my predictions aren't going to be
right and I'm going to screw up some
stuff while I'm telling you some stories
occasionally we try to address it when
it happens and I'm not I'm not sitting
here uh like I'm telling you the truth
like the truth what I'm trying to do is
make some sense I'm trying to analyze a
whole bunch of the Endless stream of
nonsense and I'm trying to filter it
with something based in reality and then
and then we can all kind of agree on
something on the other side even if we
don't agree on the on the specifics of
the policy or something so I don't have
great hope for journalism uh I have
great hope that the human Spirit wants
to
be close to something true and that
people will will keep going there
whatever that means Tim says when is
Dave's appearance on Bill Maher's
podcast going to be posted also also any
chance that bill will start posting his
podcast on Rumble so the podcast the
full it's a little over two hours at the
time it was the longest one he had ever
recorded and they wanted to go even
longer but we had to catch the red eye
to get to New York the podcast will be
up audio and video too
both on October 9th that is this Sunday
and as I said to you guys please please
watch the full thing it'll come out in
Clips as well but for those of you that
have been playing along for these last
couple years as I've talked about Bill
and how he's influenced me and how we've
you know say gone in our different
directions a little bit but I've always
maintained a respect for him despite I
think him coming to maybe some wrong
conclusions maybe that's what he thinks
of me now it's like we had we had to do
the dance the entire time and it's not
just about politics we also drank a lot
of tequila he got me to smoke weed he
asked me a lot of questions about sex
which I wasn't thrilled about uh but it
was fun and it was funny and there was a
mutual respect he asked me to come on
and do real time
um and we've been texting since and you
know what did I want if you go back to
my show the day before I left for LA
all I wanted was hey can we can we get
to a place in that conversation that
will be good to continue the
conversation and I think we did that and
uh and hopefully some of the clips will
you know catch on a bit and people will
be like hey you know these two aren't
exactly in the same spot but they're
they're doing their thing they're
challenging each other when it's
appropriate but they're kind of laughing
and joking too that's kind of the way
America used to be maybe we'd get back
do a little of that Kerry says it is it
small daily Acts or large sweeping
actions that will bring our country to a
more even Keel it's small things for
sure look what's happening in Florida
right now we have this horrific
absolutely horrific basically category
five hurricane that hit Southwest
Florida
demolishes several cities I mean you
know my feelings about Sanibel Island
that I've been telling you guys about
like this is my favorite place on earth
that is destroyed I I've actually been
thinking about a lot all week it's just
like it's just it's incredibly sad and I
don't even live there we my folks had a
vacation place there imagine these
people that just absolutely lost
everything but look at all of the people
that are chipping in people whether it's
donating money or time or resources or
handing out water or bring in whatever
skills they have uh trucks to deliver
supplies whatever it's like these are
the little things that bring us together
that's how a society is supposed to
flourish like bottom up people having
connections with each other and then
hopefully you have this like little thin
layer of government on top of you that
somewhat keeps the glue together right
it puts borders so that not everybody
can come in it defends some basic
freedoms that's how it's all supposed to
work I don't think some sweeping action
stuff is really what could happen I do
think that there are some political
answers of course it's like if the
Republicans get the the house and the
Senate can they reverse some of the woke
stuff can they reverse some of the
equity stuff
um Can can some of those things can we
put in can we put policies in place to
make sure we don't lock people down
again and force people to be injected
thing with things against their will of
course all of those things are possible
but all of that only happens if
individual people start voting first so
it's always about it's always about you
the individual first the men you figure
out a way to shift the system uh Kathy
says congratulations on baby two how do
you think the next bundle of joy will
impact your daily life
I would imagine less sleep I would
imagine more pooping and crying and
screaming and then of course the kids
are involved and uh
it still works that one and uh or were
you crying out of misery for that that
one that wasn't a laugh that was like
we've heard this joke too many times
Dave
um
I don't I mean it's just going to be
Fuller it's just going to be like more
of everything it'll sort of be like the
ending of Muppets Take Manhattan if you
haven't seen that in a while I recommend
you see it uh at the end you know
they're putting on Kermit and Miss Piggy
and everybody they're putting on this
show and they can't figure out why the
show's not quite right it's a good show
but it's not great and then it hits
Kermit after he was hit by the car you
you've all seen the movie you know what
happens uh he realizes he just needs
more chickens and more pigs and
everything else and then it'll be bigger
and better so I think that's the
situation that we're at right now did
any of that make any sense you followed
along that Delaney says you learn and
assess situations quickly you're very
bright and quick thinking I like this
Delaney guy and you also have a strong
Allegiance and heart for America can you
ever see yourself running for president
uh no no I the one thing that I maybe
could do I it was the joke amongst my
family that I would maybe one day be
mayor of Sanibel that I could be mayor
of a small town that was an island and
get to know people and help little
things on the margins make sure people
could build quicker and that the beaches
are clean and that kind of stuff uh
hopefully Sanibel will be rebuilt and
maybe I could do that one day maybe the
the bigger thing like it's so evil I
don't think I have it in me and
especially as a new father now like the
idea of like getting out there and doing
that I will always be in the fight
especially if Governor DeSantis is to
run like I hope I can be out there
fighting if I was to ever get a call
about like a press secretary job or
something I think I could do that for a
little bit like sort of out of pure fun
I think or you know just pure joy of
destroying the media but the other part
of the political thing until we until
we're able to really change the system
um I I don't know that I could do what
it would take take to to win
that's kind of it Mama Bear Perez says
hey Dave it's is it a reasonable is it
reasonable to expect a vice president to
know basic geography for example
cardinal directions as well as
geopolitical nuances that might affect
the entire world if one were to mix them
up I think you're talking about South
Korea and North Korea I suppose language
and public speaking skills are just too
much to also require such a position
what to think of big Kamala and her
alphabet soup moment in Korea
none of it should surprise anybody right
you know it nobody likes this woman she
was installed because the machine
thought that she would be the easiest
one to push Biden across for the
diversity quota and all of that stuff
and now they've got a big mess on their
hands because they have a president
who's breaking down and a vice president
who is not bright and that nobody likes
and they're watching the results of all
of their policies destroy their party
so good luck with all of that uh all
right last one Talia says what's a place
you've never been to but have always
wanted to visit Japan for sure I've
wanted to go for years and years we
thought we maybe could have a trip that
then got canceled because of covid but I
kid you not from the first time I think
I probably opened up an 8-bit Nintendo
video game and I saw a made in Japan on
the back like I thought this is the
place of video games and Transformers
and robots and electronics and I've just
always wanted to go to Japan I do love
the sushi I'd like what's his name Jiro
Jiro is it hero hero Love Sushi Jiro
Jiro I want that guy to make me some
sushi
um I really would love to go to Japan
and I hope that I don't know what their
covid policies are now and backs and
unbacks and all that but yeah Japan
would be the spot uh all right we got a
cold close for you in just a moment just
a reminder to like And subscribe to our
videos particularly at rumble.com Ruben
report if you want to submit questions
for next week go to
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with Dennis Prager is up right
now and the full thing's already up on
locals there is no show tomorrow Friday
because I am most likely in the hospital
uh with the baby all good let me just
reset over the weekend get home get
settled we should be back in here on
Monday have a great weekend everybody
getting a good picture
nice and handsome
thank you